foreign
course at this gym and I don't know if I
can continue doing that now that I know
things that I can't unknow about this
individual who owns and Loans this place
I found out recently that he was
investigated for sex acts with a minor
[Music]
yo yo yo yo what's up this is John with
the Dr John deloney show
greatest mental health and marriage
podcast ever
so glad that you've joined us talking
about relationships talking about dating
talking about marriage talking about
trying to figure out what to do next in
your life
what's wrong with your kids schools
whatever you got going on I'm here to
walk alongside you as we figure it out
if you want to be on the show go to John
deloney.com ask a-s-k John deloney.com
ask or go to uh give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 and a little bit of
housekeeping please take 13 seconds and
hit subscribe on YouTube hit the like or
thumbs up button or whatever device
you're listening to this please hit the
Subscribe button it makes such an
important difference the like button
whatever it is and if you have it in
your heart to leave a five-star review
it really kicks the show up into the
algorithms and it gets it in front of
other people our show continues to grow
at such an obnoxious Pace it's just
really staggering to watch it that's
because folks like you are continuing to
recommend it to your friends send
episodes out
um listen to it over and over again and
I'm just so grateful so continue to help
out your neighbors that way and for the
best supplements I can't say the best in
the world the ones I use the ones my
family uses my wife my kids everybody we
are a thorn family t-h-o-r-n-e go to the
everybody in the booth uses oh man
um There When My Friends Ask okay what
supplement should I take I tell them
Thorne t-h-o-r-n-e go to
www.thorn.com
you slash deloni and they get 25 off
everything in the entire store it's the
best deal you're gonna find on
supplements and they are world class so
if you're a supplement kind of person
taking fish oil creatine whatever it is
I Got You
www.thornthorne.com Youth slash deloni
am I getting it oh you got it right we
were just uh your your Texas was really
heavy there www I know it comes out
sometimes
why you gotta make the fun because mine
does too so I can do that
listen
listen America get your supplements from
Thorn pew pew pew all right let's go to
Patrick in Grand Rapids what's up
Patrick
hey Dr John how are you this show is
rapidly devolving so help us out man
I guess the reason
we really I'm just struggling with
balance in my life and kind of the
question I had was uh how can I better
prioritize my family kind of with
everything going on what you got going
on
uh so right now at this stage of my life
I'm in medical residency uh which means
I work a ton and I work like 70 to 80
hours a week
and so at a baseline I'm just not home
frankly as much as I'd like to be to
spend time with my family and even when
I am home
I just find myself thinking about people
I took care of that day or how I could
have better you know interacted with
somebody and so I'm not even even when
I'm there I'm not always mentally there
yeah absolutely
um and how much longer do you got in
residency
uh another two years okay and then where
to
uh I'm not really sure after that are
you are you doing a specialty post-doc
are you going directly into private
practice what are you gonna go do
so I'll be in family medicine and uh I
to you know help pay for some of the
school stuff I signed a government
contract so I'll be doing some
government work okay are you in the
service
uh yeah yep what's that commitment 100
years uh yeah forever
um from right now it's gonna be close to
nine years okay is that gonna have to be
is it gonna be full time is that gonna
be as needed no it's going to be full
time
okay
how much of this challenge are you
looking down the road and saying this is
going to be the next decade of my life
versus this is the next
um two years of my life
that uh I mean it's kind of both
um I mean I know what the next two years
look like I don't know what the next
time after this
okay it's really hard to think too much
about it because I don't know what the
state of the world's gonna look like or
where I'm going to be or where they're
going to send me oh so you can get
deployed over the next 10 years too
uh yeah yeah okay okay
how old are your kids man
uh just one on the way coming here soon
in a couple weeks congratulations man
that's exciting thanks it's exciting
um so
here's a couple things I think I would
keep in mind and a couple of
things that I had to navigate I never
went to med school but
there's some similar we've got some
similar trajectories and I'll walk you
through some of it the first thing is
you signed what's essentially
um you have 10 years left on the
commitment you signed
the faster you make peace with that
reality and don't fight it
the more energy you will have to spend
on adjusting your life and your schedule
and your routine and your overall
Wellness which allows you to be the dad
and husband you want to be
um it gives you more energy and
perspective on those things that
actually matter
the more you walk around pissed off that
you've got 10 more years and I don't
know where I'm going to be and this and
that the the less time and focus you
have on the other stuff is that fair
yeah yeah absolutely so I think there's
something important about saying yeah
this is cool I get to serve my country
and I get to a kid and maybe more are
going to get a ringside seat to what
service looks like both on at the
individual level taking care of an
individual patient
um at the community level at the
national level so I I think there's some
really remarkable insights that that
you'll be able to pass on to your kids
how's your marriage man
uh I'm good as good as it could be with
a nine month pregnant right yeah yeah
yeah absolutely you're in it right so
things are chaos
um how was it before
I could okay actually really good she's
she's the best thing that's ever
happened to me honestly have you ever
asked her
how she sees you doing
I don't think in those specific terms as
much no it was an important uh moment
for my marriage when my wife looked me
in the eye and said I'm tired of
watching my husband die right before my
eyes
because I was working myself to death
and she had never spoken that directly
to me before but there was something
powerful to the point that now I ask her
at some regular intervals
how am I looking but not like it I'm not
posing down I'm not all oiled up and
flexing but how am I looking she'll say
man you look great like
you're present with us or I'm giving her
permission to say I haven't seen you in
three weeks even though I've been home
every night see what I'm saying so
sometimes if you have a good connection
with your wife she can be a remarkable
mirror for
the man that she loves right right
before her okay so
um
here's what I've had to do over the
years
is I've had to create an off-ramp for
myself between
working in the messy lives of people
showing up for clients or patients
whatever you want to call them showing
up in crisis situations and then showing
up for my wife and kids
and you're going to have to learn that
toggle between dealing with somebody
coding somebody telling a loved one that
their loved one has died and then
showing up to a soccer game
it's hard
and so I would recommend strongly over
the next few years creating a practice
that you can live by that's going to
give you the tools to be able to shut
this sucker down this person passed away
today I wish I'd been kinder to this
woman I wish I'd told this woman that
she has cancer in a different way
I'm going to learn that I'm going to
have a process I'm gonna have a journal
where I write this down I'm going to
write myself a small note that says I
forgive you and next time we're gonna do
better and I'm closing this journal and
this part of my day is over and now I'm
gonna go be with my family and that's
just I just made that one up on the spot
it can be a quick stop at a gym at a gym
it could be going to grit get um coffee
sometimes I call friends on the way home
I have a 30 minute commute and it's
become really important for me because
it allows me to shut these calls off and
then go home and be present with my kids
but at the end of the day it's you being
intentional about a process and choosing
I'm not going to bring my patients into
my house
you there yeah yep I'm here does that
sound does that sound possible or does
that sound crazy no no I think I think
that's great I I don't think I know
really the balance yet on uh yeah
sharing things with my wife about my day
and how much just to like leave at the
hospital
I can tell you from personal experience
I almost buried my wife with my garbage
and I with the details of my garbage and
I almost broke my marriage up when I
decided to go the other way and hold all
of it to myself
so the balance that I've struck in my
house and so like for there's not I
don't know any clinical data that would
suggest otherwise you and your wife
gonna have to figure out what's best for
y'all
um some Partners may want to hear more
details Others May like I don't want to
know
um my wife and I landed on hey I had a
really rough night last night
or at a really tough session yesterday
and then my wife knows it's hard
and
um but she doesn't have to watch me
carry on the hey I had my hands inside
of a patient yesterday as they bled out
or I had to tell a mom that her
four-year-old son had died some of the
horrific things I've had to do
I I or and you will have to do and you
have done that's a lot of burden to put
on somebody and this is gonna sound
crazy when I say it like this
our bodies have a built-in mechanism for
dealing with reality in front of us it
has less of an ability to reconcile it
when it's just info meaning when you are
with somebody saving their life doing
CPR your body is cycling through
cortisol and adrenaline and
it is pumping through your body you have
an exit release you are running you are
moving you're reading charts you are in
this thing and those chemicals are
cycling through your body as they should
you come home and sit down and dump that
story on your wife and those chemicals
discharging her even at a lesser degree
and they got nowhere to go
right you see what I'm saying and so
yeah but again every couple's different
are you feeling her getting burned out
I think I'm probably more on the other
end where I just don't tell her anything
and she's uh she's waiting for me to
tell her something about my day please
don't please don't do that income please
don't do that you'll create an alternate
you'll create an alternative life for
yourself that's apart from your wife
and it's a tricky balance make no
mistake it's a tricky balance
and when you have a kid when your kid
comes and your kid can can y'all can
start having conversations in three or
four years there'll be something really
important about saying Daddy had a
really hard day today
he had to see some things that were sad
that's such a gift to your kids
um okay
um but coming home and saying man I saw
somebody whose hand got cut off like
that's not going to be helpful to a
five-year-old right right right so it's
finding that balance but
um
yeah I mean I I
give your wife the gift of letting her
love you
okay
and I guess maybe sit down and ask her
what that means and you know maybe I'll
can figure it out together
yeah
why are you nervous about it no I
guess I just need to sit down with her
and figure out like how much she wants
to know and what is like what is
getting a better gauge from her of what
is too much because I part of me is
afraid that like I don't want her to
I don't want her to experience some of
the things that I have and even if it's
second hand from me like I don't want to
feel like a burden to her
or like my my burdens become her burdens
there it is right there
she signed up to carry your arms in the
desert when you can't
and you sign that up for her
and so don't don't take her love for you
away
and there's a way to be abusive with
that Insight right there's a way to I
mean you can you could shut a party down
pretty quick right
yeah yeah yeah you and if you're like me
you probably have on a cake you you
sound like somebody who's got a little
more diplomacy than I do I learned early
on oh I should never tell these stories
to anybody I think I've uh I've slipped
up a little one too many times and so I
I tend to withhold yeah listen you will
never be a burden to your wife
unless you come home and just start
throwing blood and guts in her face and
she has asked you not to do that
um
in fact it becomes more of a burden if
you hide yourself from her that's
burdensome
because she's gonna walk around
wondering what she did wrong that keeps
her from being trustworthy to you she's
gonna walk around all day wondering
what it is about her that you don't love
enough to have a story to invite her
into your life that's burdensome
but coming home and telling her hey I
had a really hard hard day
what I really need is fill in the blank
I really need to hold your hand and
watch TV and put our feet up and let's
eat
let's eat shamefully tonight
let's just get off the rails
or what I really need is for you and I
to go for a walk or I need 30 minutes by
myself I saw some hard things today I'd
have some tough conversations and it was
really bad and
man what a gift that can be let her love
you let her love you let her love you
and don't fight this commitment you got
10 years you got 10 years and you're
gonna be upset when you have to miss
t-ball games and dance recitals you're
gonna that's hard stuff
and the other side of it is you get to
live a life of service and purpose that
millions and millions and millions of
people are desperate for right now as
they're walking aimlessly around waiting
for AI to take their job
and you've made a commitment bigger than
yourself to say I love people I'll never
meet
and I'm willing to go first and so I'm
grateful for you man
thank you so much for the call Brother
we'll be right back
hey John deloney here I say it all the
time you can't wish your way to a better
life it boils down to being intentional
about what you do every day intentional
acts become healthy habits and one of
the most important things you can do to
improve your mental and physical health
right now starting tonight is to get
enough quality sleep and I know this
from personal experience and for me
great sleep starts with an incredible
mattress and that's why I love dream
Cloud mattresses whether you're a back
sleeper a stomach sleeper or a side
sleeper because your dumb dog is always
in the way dream Cloud's combo of gel
memory foam and coil technology keeps
you cool and comfortable all night long
and right now dream cloud is running
their biggest offer ever 40 off all
mattresses plus an additional fifty
dollars in savings exclusively for my
listeners visit dreamcloudsleep.com and
enter a promo code John deloney that's
dreamcloudsleep.com and promo code John
deloney
we are back hey I want to give a shout
out to the Great
Tavern Dillard
the comedian look him up on on Instagram
he's hilarious he came uh to an event
that we met up in Los Angeles he brought
me this red shirt he gave me a couple of
cool shirts it's one of the funniest
guys on social media tavin Dillard is um
it's not his real name but I don't even
know if he wants his real name out there
so we'll just go with Tavern check him
out he is incredible we all know a
Tavern Dillard all right let's go out to
uh Denise in Raleigh what's up Denise
hey Dr John thank you so much for taking
my call today of course how we doing
I mean it'd be hard pressed to be better
but that's cool what's up
for you
um I have been in martial arts for
probably about 12 years now with a
particular uh black belt at a jiu jitu
gym for the past six I found out
recently that he was investigated or sex
acts with a minor
um the police department involved felt
that they had enough to make a case but
the parents opted not to press charges
to prevent a public hearing that
involves their daughter
um I was not aware of it when it
happened this all happened I guess a
year ago but I found out recently I
teach a women's self-defense course at
this gym
um and I don't know if I can continue
doing that now that I know things that I
can't unknow about this individual who
owns and owns this place
have you talked to him directly
I am in a little bit of a tough
situation there because I was told by
someone else who left the gym about six
months ago I stumbled across them on
social media and they left over this
issue
I then I didn't want to get into a well
he said this about you so I left kind of
situation I verified it with the chief
of police in our our cities like the
local police department that did the
investigation
and they also said that he you know the
police chief said this is being told in
confidence because the case was closed
without charges but yes it's true
um so I can't go to him and say that you
know people who aren't supposed to be
saying this about you told this to me
but I did tell him that I was told by
people who work in local law enforcement
recently that
um their personal opinion was that women
were not safe at this particular gym
which is true if they did say that and
it was a personal opinion not a
professional opinion and that until I
understood why they would say that about
our gym I was not going to continue
teaching the women's class or
encouraging women to train there what
was his response by the way
hell yeah good for you I'm proud of you
for that that's that was a hard
conversation wasn't it it was yeah I
kind of wanted to throw up after I got
off the phone well I'm proud of you good
for you how was that conversation
received
uh he went into some other things I
guess he had had an affair with a
different woman at some other point in
his life and said that he thought that
was why they said that about him and
that he never presumed to be a perfect
person and I was like no we all know
that about you we know you're not a
perfect person but you and your wife
were separated and then we ended up
getting back together and moving on
whatever this is something completely
different
and it's local like it's recent and he
was like oh I don't know what that's
about yeah I'd walk away I'd walk away
you fudged on it yeah I'd walk away and
the gym I was a part of I was not a part
of it for 12 years I was a part of it
gosh several years I've only been at
this one for six but yeah not six long
enough but I'm telling you I understand
that that's you're I'm asking you to
leave your family
yeah like it's it's where you spend your
time it's where you've had Great
accomplishments it's where you've
overcome failure it's already been hurt
and had people rally around you
it's a tall order to walk away
but I am not going to put my my name
next to somebody that is a knowing
sexual predator especially with children
uh just with a period at the end and I
was going to say especially if I'm
inviting women into this space taking
their money that's going to pay for this
dude's rent
yeah I can't I mean I couldn't get in
good conscience do that but I couldn't I
couldn't take 15 men and bring them in
there and make that guy one penny richer
with
um
on yeah I I I'd walk away and I hate you
there's no way to guarantee that he
wouldn't he wouldn't do it again and and
it was with a young girl at the gym too
so it just made it all more all the more
kind of in my face is like wow I can't I
can't do this because well again with
one of the women that you invite here
yeah and you you know as well as I do
I hope this doesn't sound bad to the
audience who hasn't been a part of these
gyms but there's there's never layers I
mean there's always layers there's never
levels to sexual assault but I
particularly find when martial arts
instructors are groomers
um and it's rare so don't you think this
is a thing like I am wait till my
daughter goes and does martial arts so
it's not that at all but there is a
power hierarchy there and a power
Dynamic and a respect Dynamic that's
such an integral part of the class that
doesn't exist in so many other social
spaces
that the violation is so deep and
egregious
yeah
you know what I mean I walked away from
the
police that's exactly what he did yeah
yeah
um I mean if you're my sister I would
tell you
to never walk back in that gym again
okay everybody hear you say that because
I told him I was at least taking a break
and possibly never coming back and he
texted me today asking if I could cover
the next two weeks of women's classes of
course he did geez Louise I thought we
had a conversation about this yeah he
doesn't give a crap what you think
um
you're just one of the women that makes
him money I I he here's the here's I
want to I'm going to walk you through
how I thought through this okay
sure because I also have been doing
sexual assault investigations for most
of my career and okay I understand
there's two sides to every story okay
the fact that you have worked with him
side by side for six years
you have had a
um Mentor mentee relationship
you've been through him through a
marriage breakup you now are an employee
and he didn't have the
honor and dignity of either telling you
yeah I really screwed up or
hey this story is going out there about
me and it's not true and here's what
happened
instead he said I think you're stupid
and I'm just gonna play dumb
so if he had called you and said Hey
listen this story is going on about me
that I hooked up with a minor it is not
true it's just simply not
um you're you're in North Carolina the
consent age is insanely low there like
yeah like this is what this is It's it
that's I I won't respect what he did
manipulated the consent age yeah
intentionally he had known the girl
since she was 14 and he waited until she
was 16. yeah I mean yeah
so in his mind I didn't commit a crime I
did exactly what the law said and
um cool that
what I was looking for there is his
Integrity to have a conversation with
you he didn't do that
and so yeah and by the way I don't care
what that law is I'm not gonna hang out
with grown men who sleep with 16 year
olds I'm just not I don't want those
people in my life I'm not going to learn
from those people I'm not gonna go have
drinks with those people
I don't care what the law is that's
disgusting it's disturbing
can I ask a
secondary question sure
you know how to navigate the second part
of this which is
uh my career is that I teach horseback
riding lessons and his daughter has
taken lessons from me for the past six
years ever since I we met each other at
the gym and he was like oh you do horses
my kid love sources can she ride with
you
and just wondering how to navigate that
moving forward because he's a grown man
he gets to make his choices
pull his daughter out then he chooses to
pull his daughter out well that's just
it he's not and I I I don't think that
she deserves to have her life blown up
over and she can't help that he's a
dirtbag so yeah and if as long as it's
not some sort of you don't see any kind
of red flag with discontinuing that part
I was going to just continue to teach I
mean her kid out here that's up to you
unless you unless you simply don't want
this being in your presence
well he's not usually the one who drops
her off and picks her up it's usually
the mom yeah that's up to you I mean
that's that's I wouldn't sleep over
that's up to you
um your relationship in that scenario is
with the kid right if he was coming out
for horseback riding lessons I might say
I probably don't want you out here
anymore
yeah but this one's a little bit
different yeah
um and I'll say this every case is
different every case has twists and
turns my guess is given the North
Carolina consent age and I think is it
yeah 16. God that's insane it's insane
um
I mean golly dude that just blows my
mind I need to take a second
um
if the consent age is is
no I forgot him I was gonna say
don't be sorry that's on me I just can't
I can't wrap my head around the fact
that it's 16.
um yeah I lost it so there you go that's
how good I am at this job
amazing you're great I enjoy listening
to you and that was one of the reasons
why I wanted to get your advice on this
because it's been it's been a lot
your values always are gonna cost you
something
oh man isn't that the truth yeah and
um walking away is gonna cost you
professionally it's going to cost you
financially it's he may blackball you at
another gym it's just gonna cost you
yeah and I don't want to hang out with
dudes who groom 14 year olds until they
become 16 year olds
do you think I have any kind of
obligation to try to explain this to any
of the women
I've been asked to keep some of it in
confidence by I wouldn't participate in
that
um I have a personal philosophy I don't
answer questions unless directly asked
and in this situation I'd probably say
I've chosen to not be around him
okay and let that be oh I remember what
I was going to say
um my guess is the consent age was 16.
and the police officers told his family
or her family
we can drag through this whole thing and
at the end of the day we think he's
going to walk
at least you've indicated that they
thought they had enough to put him in
jail and get him on a second sex on
their list but they often I think they
just didn't want the police she said the
parents didn't want the the trauma of a
public hearing for their daughter
I get that
but maybe he was going to walk anyway
I only know what I'm being told they may
man
they they think they're avoiding trauma
by keeping this whole thing quiet and I
can tell you
there will come a day when this little
girl looks at Mom and Dad and says why
didn't you protect me from that guy why
is he still out there
that's a mess I'm sorry Denise thank you
so much for thinking through this with
me and being brave and for everybody
listening I hope you can hear I tried to
paint a picture here here's here's why I
would make the decision the way I made
it I am not a fan of grenade throwing I
am a fan of getting direct information
and when something happens like this I'm
a fan of calling somebody very directly
and asking some very poignant questions
and how they respond and how they treat
me with dignity respect how they tell
the truth how they avoid it whatever
that plays a huge role in whether I'm
going to ride with you to the end of
this thing or I'm going to say okay but
your behavior is telling me you don't
want me here because you're lying to me
you're not being honest I'm going to
walk away
and um
remember at the end of the day a lie
at its core is one person looking to
another and saying
I think you're stupider than me
and I think I can withhold what actually
happened I can withhold truth you will
never know
I'm just not into people calling me
stupid it happens a lot in this job but
I don't
thank you so much for the call Denise
let me know how it all goes we'll be
we'll be rooting for you we'll be right
back
all right we're back let's go to Janelle
in Phoenix what's up Janelle
hello how's it going
it's going fairly well awesome how can I
help what's up
well I'm calling because I've got a
interesting Dynamic occurring that I
could use a little bit of health and
insight with awesome
um I went through a very difficult
divorce about five years ago I had been
married for 15 years
and the last three years of that
marriage was pretty difficult with
emotional and
um
just verbal abuse
um but when I finally made the decision
and had the strength to leave that
marriage I was completely at peace I had
no animosity or bitterness towards him
whatsoever I just wanted better for
myself and I knew that I'd done
everything you know that I could do to
make our marriage work I left no stone
unturned at the end of the day I just
didn't have a willing participant in
that marriage with me
um
the prayer prepared myself
I planned
or completely be out of my life due to
the fact that we share two children
together
but what I could not have anticipated or
prepared myself for was how he would
continue to be a part of my life through
the close associations that he maintains
with many of my close family members
she's kidding me
I wish I was why
um
well
[Music]
I don't it's it's really complicated
there's just so much to it um can I be
honest it's usually not I mean usually
there's a lot of like spinning things
and firecrackers and money is it money
does he have a lot of money
um he does yes yeah so um I do not we
split um it was a very inequitable
divorce it drove on over
two years and I finally just had to kind
of throw up my hands and walk away
because
um the peace that I left the marriage
with was leaving me and I was really
starting
to have bitterness and hatred towards
the father of my children and I just did
not want to feel that way about him okay
can I stop you right there can we let's
let's go back you hear me say this a lot
but in in on in an effort to choose
reality let's frame this in the right
way okay
okay you traded you sold
your stake in the financial claim
for peace
okay five years later three years later
you can be annoyed at yourself or
frustrated that you made that trade but
I wouldn't call it inequitable it's one
that you made
okay the second thing is
is
hatred is strong
but if the father of your kids is a
scumbag the father of your kids is a
scumbag
and if he's going to try to take the why
the mother of his kids to the cleaners
in order to leave her with nothing
that's not a person I want to be around
I've got some friends who've been
through divorce that treated each other
with such dignity and respect I laugh at
them and said man where was that you
know we're married right trying to burn
down the mother of your kids
is one of the least Noble things I can
think of
and so if he's a scumbag he's a scumbag
often I hear women who've been divorced
they they struggle with saying that
somebody's a scumbag because they think
it reflects back on you
why did I have a family with this guy
why did I stick around so long why did I
choose this person do you have anything
like that
foreign
and I don't disagree that he I mean he
he in my eyes he is a scumbag and I
think that's why it's so difficult for
me to make peace with the relationships
that he continues to have with my family
members have you told your family
members explicitly this makes me
uncomfortable
yeah I've told them that it feels very
dismissive of
um the pain and
that he's caused to me and the abuse
that I experienced in his hand
um because he's very financially
generous with them Ah that's even that
makes it worse man that means they like
to ride they like the ride
I know and so I
I had my
time I might would they would say you
know what that's very generous of you to
offer to me but I can't in good
conscience accept that gift from you
knowing how
how ungenerous you have been is that a
word did I just make words how
um the lack of generosity that you have
you know you failed to be generous or
fulfill your obligations to your former
spouse and therefore your children
um oh Janelle Janelle do you know how
many times have you played that fantasy
out in your mind
maybe three or four times I don't know
yeah right three or four thousand
the
okay I'm I I
just feel this sense I'm gonna be super
honest with you what I'm gonna say it's
gonna be really hard is that cool
yep your family has chosen him over you
and I hate that for you
I do too
this isn't about him and this isn't
about your family this is about you
listening to this conversation the
person I'm most mad at
the person I'm having the most
difficulty with is your family
not him I don't get mad at a rattlesnake
for being a rattlesnake I walk away I
don't interact with rattlesnakes
dude this is your family
and they've been my best friends and
that's that's right because they haven't
yeah
yeah I let me let me tell you we're best
friends this is how
one of my closest friends in the world
is named John and his wife is named
Jennifer and she's ride or die
she called me one time on my phone this
is years ago she said I just met
so-and-so who says they know you
here's what she followed up with are we
friends with her or not
and I said yes and she goes cool
she was saying we ride or die
are we letting somebody else in this
little group because if not cool I'm
moving on with my life
that's how best friends roll
best friends don't
see what you're gonna give them
and then as soon as you turn your back
turn to the person who hurt their
their child their sister their brother
and say hey can you make my life a
little shinier
ah man you got parsed out for 20 pieces
of silver dude it breaks my heart for
you
yeah
mine too that's like as if divorce isn't
hard enough you know and just grieving
all of that that comes with that and
then to feel like
like it's just forever altered the
Dynamics of my relationships with my
sister my best friend because two of her
children are employed by my ex
um another one of her another one of her
children
um is going through a lot of help she
and her husband are going through a lot
of health challenges and my ex has made
several donations
to them to help them which you know and
on the other hand Dr John I'm so
grateful right because he's helping my
nieces and my nephews and
getting them out of some sticky
situations but it's just so gross and it
feels calculated by him too as another
way to kind of control and manipulate
and rub in my face
um what if you what if you
completely unplugged from him
and this is me completely this is me
completely changing tracks let me say
this I'm completely changing what I said
earlier okay
so the story as it goes I feel like your
family has chosen him he's got money
he's got resources and they're gonna
they've gone that way
but what if
you just went to thirty thousand feet
and he can make all the calculations he
wants
but you're not you're not even in the
math class anymore
and he can donate money and help people
with their medical bills good on him
but I'm not going to give him another
second
and it might feel gross to you but your
friend's getting her her cancer
treatment or whatever so good good on
them
and when you show up if he happens to be
invited to a thing I'm gonna go
and your friends could know if you if
you choose to invite him over you're
choosing for me to not be here that's
fair
I'll just go
but I think the soul tax you're
expending on this dude
it's killing you right
yes it is and that's what I'm
to give him
emotional
real estate
you know and mental real estate in my
life and in my brain and I just don't
know how to
but at the same time the peop my normal
confidants
are I feel like I'm losing them you are
yeah
and the fact that you haven't forgiven
him yet
is drowning you not him
yeah I know
you got to let him go man
I know you're still mad about what
happened huh well yeah and I just I
think I'm so frustrated because I can't
even explain how at peace I was
when we finally separated I just
couldn't
imagine
all the muck he would drag me through in
the divorce and um you know when I left
I had collected I'd stayed home with our
boys for 10 years and I had collected
two paychecks from my new job when I
moved out and moved in with my parents
and I'm still there five years later
with my parents meanwhile he's bought
another business and he's purchased a
million dollar home and
I I know that it's not healthy for me to
dwell on those things you know this is
jealousy Let It Go yeah yeah it's
poisoning you
and you've heard that a million times
but
you're drinking poison hope he dies
hoping he dies
and then there's something to be said
for applauding the fact that your kids
are going to be able to go to college
because their dad's a millionaire
but five years later you're at your
parents house because you still are
choosing to be at your parents house
true or false
um I I'm priced out of the market I
could not afford to I just went back to
school finished
my degree uh second degree and I
currently working towards being able to
afford movie now yes okay
the jealousy five years and the
frustration and the poison are not worth
it he's still running your life and he's
not even there
well he is
listen
but yeah he's there more than just that
too and that's what I'm I'm wanting to
let go but it feels like I've got to let
go of
relationships in my family too which is
hard and another thing to be bitter
about right and I don't want to be it's
just
that's where I am but I want I I want to
be free of that whenever somebody hurts
us whenever somebody
violates our our
relationship
bitterness feels like we've regained
some sort of control over them
bitterness feels good sometimes
we don't talk about that enough but
being pissed off feels good
and the only problem with it is it
doesn't work
it doesn't change them or alter them
most time they don't even know
just destroys us
so you've heard me say this a thousand
times and I'll wind up saying a thousand
times more I would love for you
to go to
um
a local Home Depot and pick up a couple
of cinder blocks and put some duct tape
on them or put some masking tape on them
and write down
in the black marker on that masking tape
this man abused me and he hurt me
and he dragged me through the mud
and
he wasn't just this man he was your best
friend he was your husband he's the dad
of your kids you had plans with this guy
it was your life
and I want you to carry that cinder
block around until it gets so heavy your
hands are exhausted your shoulders are
exhausted then once you go to the
backyard in your parents house and throw
that sucker down let it sit but
consciously say I'm no longer carrying
him
and I want you to tear off that piece of
tape and wad it up and throw it away and
Mark that day is the day I decided to
stop carrying him and then over the next
couple of months when something pops up
something pops up something pops up that
thought that anger that frustration that
jealousy
you can say to yourself not carrying
that anymore and your body will have
a moment you'll have stuck a flag in the
ground it says this is the day that I
quit carrying this
and this is the day I decided to start
building something new you haven't
started building something new you're
still just sitting in the ash of what
was so pissed
is that fair
yeah it's fair
and you may have to do that that same
thing with another cinder block about
your sister
yeah and your best friend and and and
and
uh
I'm sorry
and there is a gratitude side to this
that he's a dad that still shows up to
kids stuff
and you got to grit your teeth and smile
and
you all both have to be adults for your
kids you can do that you can do hard
things like that
you can too
what you're gonna find is when he
realizes he has lost his grasp over you
the dynamic will change
I promise it will change
but until then you can practice it
and let's make a plan to get our two our
two feet underneath us
let's make a in eight months I'm moving
out of my parents house
even if it's into a small apartment
in 12 months I'm filling the blank in 16
months I'm let's begin to build
something new
and not just make snow angels in the ash
of what was our lives are so quick
they're so short
to just waste them being bitter and
angry
even when God I'm so bitter and
you're worth so much more Janelle so
much more
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of my best-selling book own your
past change your future I want you to go
through that and it will give you a road
map out
you so much for the call we'll be right
back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show uh
this is super weird but the other day uh
Kelly was in the office
wearing kind of this halter toppy thing
that was super inappropriate for work
but right underneath her armpit it's the
strangest tattoo of the Jonas Brothers
who would have thought
um I love the Jonas Brothers and I'm not
ashamed to admit it I know but most of
us don't get our loves tattooed in our
armpits but you do you all right Kelly
knows how to roll that's how she rolls
and so today's song
this Waffle House
this better not be throwing some shade
at my one of my favorite restaurants
the Jonas Brothers sing
in their poetic brilliance
hey now we never knew how to Forfeit hey
now
but we always knew how to talk hey now
couple nights through gasoline on the
fire hey now
we never knew how to perfect hey now but
we always knew it would work what are
they talking about hey now how about we
make a complete sentence because there's
something misread or if something got
said no before the night ends
no don't get distressed it's gonna get
figured out oh deep conversation at the
waffle
let's
all right that's this I think we're done
Kelly show your armpit to the screen
because that's gonna only thing no yeah
we don't want to see that hey America we
love you bye